[موسيقى]
مساء الخير ماذا حدث في اوكرانيا بينما
كنا نتابع الحرب في غزه بعيدا عن تفاصيل
العمليات العسكريه وهي كثيره في الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه هناك ثلاث متغيرات لا
مجال
لانكار الاول طوفان من التصريحات
والتحليلات العسكريه الغربيه تؤكد فشل
الهجوم المضاد الذي بداته اوكرانيا في
يونيو
الماضي هذا الهجوم كان قد طال انتظاره
وحظي بدعم غربي هائل كان الهدف منه طموح
جدا الحاق هزيمه بالروس تؤدي الى طردهم من
كل شبر احتلوه في اوكرانيا بعد فبراير
2022 بل واخراجهم من شبه جزيره القرم التي
اعلنت روسيا ضمها رسميا الى الاتحاد
الروسي في
2014 الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا تحديدا
كان عندهم امال اكبر عول على هذه الهزيمه
لتكون اكبر مسمار في نعش بوتين وانهيار
نظامه وبدايه تحول كبير في روسيا اي روسيا
جديده يقودها بعد الهزيمه نخب مواليه
للغرب فشل الهجوم المضاد لا ينكره حتى
زيلينسكي نفسه الرئيس الاوكراني قال نصا
لوكاله اسوشيتد بريس في اول ديسمبر الماضي
2023 اردنا نتائج اسرع لسوء الحظ لم نحقق
النتائج المرجوه هذه حقيقه وبرر زيلينسكي
ذلك بعدم تلقي الدعم الكافي من
الحلفاء الامر الثاني بما ان الامل في
هزيمه الروس يتبخر فقد تراجع حماس الدول
الغربيه بقياده الولايات المتحده لاستمرار
دعم اوكرانيا ماليا
وعسكريا الكونجرس بقياده الجمهوريين احبط
دفعه مساعدات جديده تقدر بنحو 60 مليار
دولار كان بايدن يرغب في ارسالها الى
اوكرانيا وفيتو بولندا منع الاتحاد
الاوروبي حتى هذه اللحظه من امداد
اوكرانيا ب 50 مليار يورو ايضا تراجع
الدعم بيعزز بدوره فرص روسيا في النصر و
يغضي على اي امل لاوكرانيا في تغيير
الاوضاع على
الارض زيلينسكي قال ذلك ايضا في حوار له
مع مجله تايم الامريكيه وانا واضع
لحضراتكم روابط كل هذه الحوارات والمصادر
كالعاده اسفل الحلقه زيلنسكي قال نسا لا
احد يؤمن بانتصاره مثلي يعني بقدرتنا على
الانتصار مثلي لا احد ويضيف اقناع حلفاء
اوكرانيا بقدرات على الانتصار يستنزف كل
قوه
وطاقته المتغير
الثالث ترتب على فشل الهجوم العسكري
الاوكراني وتراجع الدعم الغربي ان كثير من
حلفاء اوكرانيا بداوا يطرحون ليس فقط
البحث عن حل الازمه
دبلوماسيا ولكن ضروره ان تستعد اوكرانيا
للتنازل عن جزء من اراضيها لاتمام التسويه
دبلوماسيا
مسؤولين اوروبيين وامريكان تحدثوا الى
موقع ان بي سي نيوز وغيره من المواقع
الكثيره ان المسؤولين الامريكان
والاوروبيين بداوا يتفاوضون او يتحدثون
سرا مع الحكومه الاوكرانيه حول ما قد
تنطوي عليه مفاوضات السلام المحتمله مع
روسيا لانهاء
الحرب وان هذه المحادثات تضمنت الخطوط
العريضه لما قد تضطر اوكر للتخلي عنه
للتوصل الى اتفاق مع الروس التنازلات اللي
بيشوا اليها بيقصد بها محاوله الموافقه
على رغبه بوتين وقف الحرب اذا تنازل
الاوكران له عن نحو 20% من اراضيهم اشمعنى
20% ما دي هي مساحه المقاطعات الاربعه
اللي استحو عليها الجيش الروسي في شرق
اوكرانيا بعد فبراير 22
وهذه المباحثات وفقا لموقع ام بي سي نيوز
هذه المباحثات السريه جرت تحديدا بكثافه
في اكتوبر
2023 خلال اجتماع لممثلي نحو 50 دوله من
الدول الداعمه
لاوكرانيا موقع بوليتيكو الامريكي ذهب في
نفس الاتجاه مؤخرا ونقل عن
مسؤولين احدهم في الاداره الامريكيه اداره
بايدن ومسؤول اخر هو دبلوما ماسي اوروبي
يخدم في واشنطن كلاهما اتفق على التحول في
موقف حلفاء اوكرانيا من
دعمها من دعمها في ايه من دعمها لهزيمه
روسيا لدعمها لتحسين موقفها التفاوض مع
الروس لما يقودوا كلهم على مائده
المفاوضات الحقيقه احنا لسنا في حاجه
لتسريبات لمعرفه التغير في الموقف
الامريكي على الاقل هذا التغير في
السياسات يمكن ادراكه بوضوح من تغير في
عباره واحده بشكل علني كانت سياسه بايدن
وحلفائه في دعم اوكرانيا لهزيمه روسيا
تتلخص في عباره مشهوره جدا يرددها بايدن
وكل الاداره الامريكيه منذ بدء الحرب سوف
ندعم اوكرانيا مهما تطلب الامر لكن مؤخرا
استخدم البيت الابيض عباره مختلفه تماما
سوف ندعم اوكرانيا قدر استطاعتنا
يعني السياسه تحولت
من از لونج از تس لتكون از لونج از از
ويكان والفرق كبير
جدا سؤال مهم لماذا التغير الكبير في موقف
حلفاء
اوكرانيا الاجابه مركبه لان هناك اسباب
متعدده لكن اهم سبب في تقديري هو الياس
الذي تسرب في نفوس هؤلاء الحنفاء من قدره
اوكرانيا على الحاق الهزيمه بروسيا بعد
حوالي 21 شهر من بدء الحرب خلال ال 21 شهر
دول حصلت اوكرانيا على دعم غير مسبوق من
حوالي 50 دوله بتقدر اجمالي المساعدات
العسكريه وغير العسكريه من كل حلفاء
اوكرانيا منذ بدء الحرب والى الان بحوالي
350 مليار دولار فضلا عن المساعدات التي
لا تقدر بمال يعني الدعم الاستخباراتي
مثلا بالغ الحيويه لما كل الدول ديت تكشف
للاكر عن تحركات الجيش الروسي وتستبق
الروس بخطوات في كثير من مراحل الحرب هذه
مساعده لا تقدر لا تقدر بمال الاستشارات
العسكريه محاوله خنق الاقتصاد الروسي و
يعني تقييد حركه الجيش
الروسي فاذا لم تنجح اوكرانيا حتى في
اجبار الروس على انسحاب من احد المناطق
الاربعه التي اعلنوا ضمها رسميا في شرق
اوكرانيا بدايه من 30 سبتمبر
2022 فمتى وكيف وباي تكلفه يمكن ان يهزموا
الروس جريده بريفادا الاوكرانيه نشرت
مؤخرا تسريبات لما دار بين وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويد اوستن والقيادات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في نوفمبر الماضي يعني نوفمبر
ووفقا لهذه التسريبات فان اوستن صدم عندما
سمع تقديرات العسكريين الاوكران
لاحتياجاتهم الضروريه لاتمام او لتجديد
محاولتهم تحرير اراضيهم من الروؤس فقد
طلبوا 17 مليون وحده من الذخائر
المختلفه وقدروا التكلفه الاجماليه لهذه
العمليه العسكريه من
350 الى 400 مليار دولار اضافه لكل ما
اخذوه
سابقا ووفقا للصحيفه فان اوستن قال لهم ان
هذا القدر من الذخائر لا يمكن جمعه من كل
دول العالم مجتمعه اللي هي مستعده يعني ان
تعطي ما فاض عن حاجاتها لاوكرانيا دقه
التسريبات في تقديري ليست مهمه في هذه
الواقعه يعني لان نفس المعلومات وان
اختلفت الارقام تكرر كثيرا وعلنا وخلاصه
هذه
المفاوضات او المحادثات الجاريه بين
اوكرانيا والولايات المتحده وحلفاء
اخرين اوكرانيا تطلب ذخائر اكبر بكثير من
قدره الحلفاء على
انتاجها ياس الحلفاء من قدره الاوكران على
هزيمه الروس ليس مبنيا على تقديرات هي محل
خلاف مع الجانب
الاوكراني يعني مثلا مش القيادات الولايات
المتحده والدول الغربيه بتقول لاوكرانيا
انتم عاجزون عن
تحقيق الهدف وهو هزيمه الروس والاوكران
بيقولوا لهم انتم متسرع في الحكم اعطونا
فرصه لا مش هو ده الحاصل قيادات اوكرانيه
كبيره بتقر بالتقديرات الغربيه اي عجزهم
عن هزيمه الروس اهم هؤلاء على الاطلاق هو
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه الجنرال فاليري زلوج اني اللي
هو يعني قائد الجيش الاوكراني في اول
نوفمبر الماضي انفرضت مجله الايكونومست
البريطانيه بمقال تحليلي مهم جدا جدا لكل
من يعني فهم مجريات الحرب وفهم الحرب
الحديثه بصفه
عامه للجنرال وفي هذا المقال شرح الاوضاع
العسكريه في
اوكرانيا بالاضافه لمقابله مع الجنرال
يعني اجرتها مجله الايكونومست كلاهما كان
صادما في المقابله رسم زالو جيني صوره
قاتمه لوضع اوكرانيا في الحرب مؤكدا ان
الحرب مع الروس وصلت الى ستيل ميت طريق
مسدود وان النصر على الروس يتطلب يتطلب
ايه قفزه تكنولوجيه هائله في نظم التسليح
ثم يخلص الى الحقيقه المره له بالنسبه
للجانب الاوكراني على الارجح لن يكون هناك
انجاز او اختراق عسكري عميق وجميل ده يعني
كلمه جميل ده هو وصفه ضد القوات
الروسيه الاسوا ان زلوج اني اوضح في
المقال التحليلي المصاحب للحوار ان الجمود
اللي هو الستيل ميت يعني لا لا انتصار ولا
هزيمه قد يصبح هزيمه لاوكرانيا قريبا ليه
هو اوضح كده الجمود اي لا غالب ولا مغلوب
عاده يرتبط بحرب استنزاف طويله بين قوسين
ده انا اللي بقوله كما حدث في حرب العراق
وايران مثلا بين عامي 1980
و1988 نعود الى كلام
الجنرال اللي بيقول ان الحرب الطويله
كقاعده عامه قد تكون قد تكون مفيده لاحد
اطراف النزاع وفي حالتنا الخاصه والكلام
للجنرال زلوج 20ي الطرف المستفيد هو روسيا
اذ انه في حاله استمرار الصراع على هذا
النحو فسوف تنفد ذخائر اوكرانيا بينما
تستطيع روس على الرغم من العقوبات زياده
قدرته على
الانتاج على الانتاج العسكري يعني انتاج
ما تحتاجه من
ذخائر لكن الاخطر من اثر تراجع المساعدات
هو ما قاله زالو جيني عن صعوبه تجنيد
مقاتلين جدد لتجديد دماء الجيش الاوكراني
المجهد الجنرال اوضح صعوبات التجنيد بطرق
مختلفه في التحليلي لدينا امكانيات محدوده
لتدريب الاحتياط اللي هم الجنود الاحتياط
على اراضينا ليه لان العدو اللي هو روسيا
لديه القدره على ضرب مراكز التدريب قبل
اكتمال عمليه التدريب وبيقول نجد صعوبات
في تدوير او تناوب الجنود على خطوط التماس
مع الروؤس ولانه في ثغرات تشريعيه بتساعد
على التهرب تهرب بعض المواطنين الاوكران
من الخدمه كل ذلك يؤدي الى عدم قدره
اوكرانيا على تحقيق التفوق على
العدو في الاحتياطات من خال من خلال زياده
عددها عدد مين عدد الجنود الاحتياط يعني
اللي هم مطلوبين بشده عدد الجنود اللي
بيحارب في
اوكرانيا اجهد من الحرب اللي دايره من
فبراير
22 احد مساعدي زيلينسكي عبر عن نفس الفكره
لكن بشكل ابسط من كلام الجنرال اللي هو
كلام رصين وعسكري وعلمي لكن هذا المساعد
طبعا الذي لم يستطع ان يذكر اسمه لانه غير
مصرح له بان يتحدث بهذا الشكل الصريح قال
نصا كده لمجله تايم امريكيه حتى لو اعطت
الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا كل الاسلحه
التي تحتاجها فان كيف لا تملك الرجال او
المقاتلين يعني رجال او سيدات الذين
تحتاجهم لاستخدام هذا السلاح في نقص كبير
في قدره اوكرانيا على
تجديد المجندين
المقاتلين بالمناسبه قضيه التجنيد محل
خلاف عالني بين زيلينسكي وزلو جيني في 19
ديسمبر زيلينسكي الرئيس الاوكراني قال انه
يدرس طلبا من الجيش راني لارسال نصف مليون
جندي جديد يعني تجنيد نصف مليون مواطن جدد
وارسالهم الى ميدان المعركه لكنه طلب من
القيادات العسكريه على راسهم زوجيني طبعا
توضيح خطتهم بالتفصيل بشان هذه المساله
الحساسه للغايه وفي وفي
تصريحات
زيلينسكي كلام يشهي بانه الطلب غير مقنع
وانه الخطه العسكريه التي قدمت له ليست
متكامله لكن قائد الجيش نفى علنا ان يكون
قد تقدم بطلب لتجنيد هذا العدد الضخم
ملاحظتين الاولى ان لدى الجيش الاوكراني
ما يقرب من 800000 جندي حتى اكتوبر الماضي
على الجبهه ده وفقا لوزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه بالاضافه الى حوالي 200000
قوات امن مختلفه ا يعني
زي مثلا الحرس الوطني وخلافه ودول
بيواجهوا الجيش الروسي اللي تعداده بعد
يعني زياده عدد المجندين حوالي مليون و300
ال الملحوظه الثانيه ان الخلاف بين الرئيس
اللي هو زيلينسكي والجنرال زلوج يبدو ان
له اسباب اعمق تتلخص في خوف الرئيس من
طموحات الجنرال زوجيني السياسيه وال
الجنرال زلوج يعنيي شخصيه محبوبه ويعني
لها جمهور كبير داخل اوكرانيا وخارجها لكن
هذه قصه اخرى يتول
شرحها اخر نقطه جديره بال بالطرح او
بالاشاره اليها عند الحديث عن الصعوبات
الكبيره التي تواجهها اوكرانيا مؤخرا
بتتمثل في الفجوه بين زيلينسكي من ناحيه
وبعضا من كبار مسؤوليه العسكريين والسياسي
الذين يعربون عن صعوبه استمرار الحرب بعض
المستشار الرئيس الذين يتحدثون طبعا اوف
ذا ريكورد لكثير من كبريات الصحف الغربيه
والاوكرانيه اصبحوا يشعرون بالقلق لان
ايمان الرئيس بانتصار
اوكرانيا
حتمي على روسيا وبيعت قدوا انه هذا
الايمان بات قناعه روحيه وكانه نبوءه
توراتيه يؤمن بها الرئيس منفصله عن ارض
الواقع يعني واحد من هؤلاء المسؤولين قال
لمجله تايم نصا انه يخدع نفسه نفدت
خياراتنا نحن لا نستطيع ان ننتصر لكن جرب
وحا ان تخبره بذلك في اشاره الى زيلينسكي
يرفض الاستع بربما يغضب ويثور اذا سمع
تقرا تشكك قدره الجي الاكراني على
الانتصار
بعض مساعدي
زيلينسكي بيعتقدوا انه تعنته يعيق قدره
اوكرانيا على التقي على التكيف مع الواقع
الجديد اللي هو ليس لصالح اوكرانيا في
ساحه المعركه ويشعرون بالقلق من ان
التفاوض على تسويه مع روسيا يظل من
المحرمات لان زيلينسكي يعارض التجاوب مع
المتغيرات الجديده على ارض
الواقع ل نسك بالمناسبه حتى هذه اللحظه
بيرفض حتى هدنه مؤقته
في ده على اعتبار ان الروس ممكن يوافقه
يعني بيرفض حتى التفاوض على هدنه مؤقته هو
قال بالنص كده في حديث له ايضا مع مجله
تايم بالنسبه لنا اي حديث عن وقف الحرب
يعني ترك هذا الجرح مفتوحا للاجيال
القادمه ربما يؤدي ذلك الى تهدئه بعض
الناس داخل بلادنا او خارجها على الاقل
اولئك الذين يريدون انهاء الامور باي ثمن
لكن بالنسبه ل هذه مشكله لانه يبقي على
القنبله كما هي فقط يؤخر
تفجيرها كلامه لا يخلو من المنطق بس
المنطق شيء والقدره على تنفيذه شيء اخر
طبعا ايمان ز لانسكي وقناعاته بتظل محل
اعتبار في ظل الدعم الغربي لكن ان تبخر
الدعم الغربي تصبح قناعات او اهميه
قناعاته يعني محدوده جدا ماذا يمكن ان
يحمل عام 2024 في علم الله لكن المؤكد ان
الحرب لن تكن سهله والبحث عن نهايه لها لن
يكون ايضا سهلا قبول اوكرانيا بالتنازل عن
20% من اراضيها او حتى اقل اذا تم سوف
يكون امرا خطيرا ليس فقط لاوكرانيا ول
الاوكران ولكن تداعياته سوف تتجا الحدود
الاوكرانيه على النظام الدولي النظام
الدولي اللي استقر من بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه صحيح انه ودي نقطه تانيه انه
النصر بات وفقا للمعطيات الحاليه قريبا
جدا لموسكو لكن المفاجات دائما وارده
لننتظر ونرى ويكون لنا ان شاء الله مع
تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه حلقه اخرى باذن
الله اشكركم والى اللقاء